-We are in the Doom Box.
Our next three songs will decide
tonight's champions.
It's time for
"Slay It, Don't Spray It."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ I don't know, but I don't
wanna get sprayed ♪
-Here's how this works --
On your turn, you're gonna have
to sing a well-known song
karaoke-style.
You'll have the lyrics
in front of you,
but when the music drops out,
you have to finish the line
from memory.
If you don't get the lyrics
exactly right,
those microphones will spray you
and your partner in the face.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, but if you can slay it and
sing all the words perfectly,
then your opponents
get drenched instead.
Each song is worth
50,000 points.
Jabari, Quavo,
your team is up first.
-Let's go, then.
-Let's see what song you get.
-Let's do it.
[ Computer beeping ]
-"Rapper's Delight,"
Sugarhill Gang!
-I'm good with this one.
-All right, good.
-Yeah, I got this one, then.
-Wait, you're gonna do
the whole song?
-Yeah, yeah.
-To this one.
-"Rapper's Delight"?
-Yeah.
-You're --
-I'll do the next one.
-You're Quavo, though!
-But I'll do the next one.
-All right, bud.
You're making the call
on this one.
-Watch this.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Okay.
Whenever you're ready, Jabari.
Good luck.
-I'm ready.
♪♪
-Uh-oh.
Hey.
-Whoo, whoo!
[ Cheers and gasps ]
-Spraaayed!
-Got 'em.
-Get 'em, get 'em!
-I'm sorry, dude!
-They sprayed!
-[ Laughs ]
-Disrespect, I'm sorry.
You're a champ.
You nailed it!
-What can I say? I'm a--
-You crushed it.
-I'm an old soul.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's 50,000 points
for your team.
Let's see that in slow motion.
-Ohhh!
[ Crowd laughs ]
Ohhh!
-[ Chuckles ]
-[ Laughs ]
-You're that cool?
How cool are you,
French Montana?
You don't even react to --
-Nah, I moved to the right.
-Oh, I understand. I understand.
Yeah, yeah, gotcha, gotcha.
French and Chance,
it is your turn.
Let's see what song you get.
[ Computer beeping ]
-Oh, no.
-You guys are --
-Oh.
-I don't know this one.
-"American Woman"
by Lenny Kravitz!
-Y'all don't know that.
-Nope.
-That's eclectic.
-Who's gonna sing this one?
-Chance.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah, okay, okay.
All right.
French, don't move out
of the way of the water,
you know what I mean?
-[ Chuckles ]
-You're sticking to the wall
a little bit there.
All right. All right.
[ Laughs ]
Chance, you're laughing already.
You don't look confident to me,
that's all I'm gonna say.
-Let's just get it over with.
-Re-- [ Laughs ] Whenever
you're ready, let's hear it.
♪♪
-Chance is good!
-Nope.
♪♪
-♪ And I gotta sing this song ♪
All right, spray me. Go ahead.
-Nooo!
[ Laughter ]
-Can't come out.
And you had no clue.
You had no clue.
Okay, it just --
-I don't know
none of these songs!
He gave 'em "Rapper's Delight"!
-[ Chuckles ]
-All right.
It's "than spend my time
growing old with you"
was the lyric right there.
That's 50,000 points
for Jabari and Quavo.
Let's do that again
in slow motion right there.
[ Laughter ]
French, he did it again!
He moved out of the way again!
Oh, my God, it's so funny.
All right, look.
It's time for the final round,
and we're really gonna raise
the stakes on this one.
Watch your heads because we've
got the big mics coming in.
-Hope you brought a poncho,
honcho! [ Laughs evilly ]
-Oh.
-French, you see that?
-Whoo.
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
All four of you are going
to take turns singing,
so pay attention to your screen.
You'll switch off line-by-line
when the music stops.
You have to nail the lyrics
or you and your partner
will get drenched.
-Uh-oh.
-This round itself
is worth 200,000 points.
Whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
-Oh, man.
-Look at how dry and happy
you guys are!
-Dry!
-[ Chuckles ]
-Let's see
what our final song is.
[ Computer beeping ]
"All Star" by Smash Mouth!
-We got this.
-All right. Quavo, you are
going to start us off.
♪♪
-♪ I ain't
the smartest tool in the shed ♪
-French, you're up next!
-♪ She was lookin' kinda dumb ♪
♪ With her fingers
or her thumb ♪
♪ In the shape of an "L's"
her forehead ♪
[ Chuckles ]
-♪ Well, years start coming
and they don't stop coming ♪
♪ Things had rules
and the ground hit running ♪
-[ Singing indistinctly ]
♪ Her brain gets smart,
but your head gets dumb ♪
♪ So much to -- ♪
Oh.
-♪ So much to say,
so what's wrong ♪
♪ With taking
the back street? ♪
-♪ You never know
if you don't -- ♪
[ Rapping ] ♪ Don't never shine
if you don't glow ♪
♪♪
-Chance, you're up!
-♪ Hey now, you're a rock star,
get the show on, get paid ♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Bell dings ]
-That's not right!
That's not right!
-Spray them! Spray them now!
-That's not right!
-Spray them now!
Spray them now!
[ Overlapping shouting ]
Jimmy, spray them now!
-No! No, you're not!
No, you're not!
-♪ Hey now, you're a rock star,
get the show on, get paid ♪
[ Bell dings ]
Ohhh!
-Chance, this time,
you were correct!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
They said it was right!
Let's give 'em one more spray
and let 'em know what's up!
-What?
-Yeahhh! Yeah!
-Yeahhh!
-Oh, y'all kidding, right?
-Are they kidding?
-[ Yelling in slow-mo ]
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
-We have a winner!
French and Chance are today's
"That's My Jam" champs!
Come on out!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right here. French.
You got it, bud.